so you're able to soak in information
integrate it and be quickly take notes
generally I think I'm pretty good at
that yeah what uh you do this a lot when
you stream your typing stuff is there a
system in that note taking and what note
what do you use for note taking uh
doesn't matter I use a notepad like
notepad the original pad yep notepad.exe
not the plus plus not is there genius to
the madness behind that or you just
don't give a [ __ ] no I mean like it's
gonna depend on the style of
conversation if I'm with somebody that
is very meticulously organized their
thoughts and they're a uh find a better
word here for Rambler you can edit that
and better word for Rambler yeah
something that talks a lot a lot I'll
start like taking notes bullet points
like this this this this this this
because um there's a style of
conversation where I say seven or eight
different things and then when you go to
respond to everything I said I cut you
off immediately and we argue that point
but if somebody's going to do that it's
just like hold on you just said these
eight things I'm going to respond to
every single one I've written them all
down and then you can go if you want to
go Point by point we can but you just
said all this and I wrote it down it's
not we're gonna go so what do you
actually writing down like a couple
words per point they left honestly like
there are very few unique conversations
in politics like a lot of them are kind
of retreading old ground so for having a
debate on abortion
um somebody might say like oh well I
believe this thing about viability and I
believe this thing about you know when
they're a fetus versus a human and I'll
just write down like those points so
that when I go to respond I kind of have
like uh like note cards like a guiding
thing there to keep me centered on my
response political discourse is the kind
of tree you're walking down I got it and
you're like taking just to keep my focus
guided so I'm not like running off in a
weird tangent or responding to something
I didn't say or something yeah what
about like doing research is just is
there a system to your note-taking
because mentally you seem to be one of
the most organized people I've listened
to so is there is it in your mind or is
there a system that's on paper a little
of both I feel like the human mind is a
beautiful thing if you have interest in
an area uh so like what I'll tell people
is let's say there's like a totally new
topic that I'm researching I don't know
anything and I'll do a couple of these
on stream I think they're born people
watch it I might open a Wikipedia
article and I'll read and I have
something I don't know and then I open
the next Wikipedia article and I'll read
it and then I might have like seven tabs
open and I'll read and I'll read and
I'll read
um and I'll read a ton of stuff maybe
for hour two three four hours of stuff
and then by the end you know someone in
chat will ask me like do you even
remember like this particular thing and
I'll say not really no not too much but
what happens is as long as you've seen
it once what will happen is like the
next day the day after we'll read
something else and be like oh I remember
that thing from this thing I remember
like vaguely that and then if you see it
like a third time you're like oh this
makes sense because especially when it
comes to oh here's like a little trick
on stuff if you're ever reading any news
and there's a place that pops up always
look at it on a map because so much of
history is like on a map it's so
important to like know the geography it
makes things make so much more sense
um but yeah once I once I start to see
stuff over and over again just because
I've like read it a few times stuff will
start to kind of connect to my mind and
like oh yeah well this makes sense of
course these people believe this because
of this or of course like this happened
here it's because you know that happened
there
um so yeah it's a lot of that if there's
like a topic that I'm doing specific
research for so like vaccine related
stuff is a big one the Ukrainian Russian
conflict is a big one that I'll break
out a note um I'll probably get like a
Google doc and I'll just start like
writing like an outline of kind of the
rough points of everything just to
organize my thoughts around different
topics yeah